[Music]
today
shawn and i are going to be talking
about r python a data science love story
and why we're very excited to bring this
news to you
so starting off giving a bit of an
overview we'll be talking about
why uh we're really excited to bring r
and python together
in our studio and provide it to the data
science teams
that we work with in this webinar
specifically what we're going to want to
show you
is how data scientists can use r and
python together
on a single data science project how
devops and i.t can support this
bilingual group of data scientists
in their development efforts in a single
development infrastructure
and how these bilingual data science
teams can efficiently collaborate and
share their work
with their business stakeholders so that
the insights that they generate
can actually be used to make better
data-driven decisions
we'll wrap up then talking a little bit
about our ongoing community investment
from our studio in both the rn python
communities
and then we'll talk about how we can how
you can get more information on any of
the points we discussed today
as well as answer as many questions as
we can
next slide please
so over the years
the focus of our studio has been how do
we help organizations really realize the
full value of their data science
investments
complementing the large investments in
open source data science
that we've made to the beginning of our
company
as part of that it's been in our dna to
really focus on how do we integrate
with all the tools and environments that
data scientists need to use to do their
work
early on we introduced shiny which is a
way of building interactive web-based
visual applications using pure our code
we also have done a lot of integration
with spark
through our sparkly r package and we've
also done
a lot of work to make it easier to
access data
use sql and integrate with databases so
all along we've had this focus
on integrating with all the tools that a
data scientist might need
in the last few years as we've talked to
our data science customers
we've seen that there are a lot of
bilingual data science teams
a lot of teams that really need to use
both r and python together
in order to exploit the best of both
environments
and so with the last couple years we've
added a focus on integrating with
various capabilities on the python side
that started off with integration with
tensorflow which led to our development
of the reticulate package
as a way of providing general
integration with python from the r
language which sean will be talking
about in a moment
and then most recently over the last
year or so we've introduced a number of
new capabilities around python
including the uh
support for jupiter notebooks and
jupiter lab
within our commercial products which
sean will be talking about
next slide
so in talking to our customers and other
data science teams out there
we've seen a lot of common challenges
for these bilingual data science teams a
lot of the same problems that they
struggle with
data scientists for example are focused
on using
and finding the best tool for the job
and when they're trying to use r and
python together that means they often
need to switch context between these
multiple different environments and they
struggle with the
just the cognitive switching and doing
that to support that switching
devops and i t have to spend time and
resources to maintain and manage and
scale these separate environments for r
and python
in a cost effective way often struggling
with that
because they might not have the skills
in the open source tools
that underlie both environments
data science leaders the the people who
manage and
really try and maximize the value and
efficiency of these data science teams
russell with how to share results
consistently and deliver value to the
large organization
because ultimately the data science team
is there to provide insights
that can help the organization make
better decisions the data science
leaders also want to focus on how do we
provide the tools for collaboration
between these r and python users
because if these users are siloed then
they might end up reinventing the same
algorithms the same processes the same
analyses
in these different environments and
wasting time and effort
doing that and then the business
stakeholders are
ultimately not interested typically in
the underlying details in whether or not
the data science products that they
receive are based on r and python
they just want to make sure that those
that data science is credible
and that they're able to leverage those
insights in order to make better
decisions
so these are the type of challenges that
we've seen
throughout many many conversations with
different data science teams and so
we're very excited today to
bring you um a view into how we help
solve those challenges
and with that i'll hand it off
awesome thank you so much lou and again
thanks everyone for joining
uh we're going to start by looking at
some of the ways that a data scientist
might combine r and python
and this is something that's near and
dear to my heart because before joining
our studio
i sat exactly in the seat i was working
with some really amazing engineers
who were doing all their their stuff in
python i came from more of a stats
background this was more comfortable
with r
and i found myself spending a lot of
time on pretty
tedious tasks running python scripts
saving data to disk
loading it back up in r to make a plot
debugging
when type conversions didn't work just
things that that weren't very fun
uh and i'm excited today to show you as
a data scientist
how in our studio with the open source
reticulate package
you can really work around a lot a lot
of that and very efficiently combine
these two languages together
so we're going to start with a couple of
examples so i'm going to switch
over to rstudio and actually want to
show you
a shiny application and this is an
application
i inherited from that prior life
basically what it allows uh someone to
do
is compare the fuel economy of two
different vehicles going from
point a to point b and so you know maybe
as an example
we could look at a ford explorer versus
a toyota highlander hybrid a simulation
occurs under this behind the scenes here
uh
and then we get the result in this case
the uh
ford explorer uses more gas than the
hybrid
so this is an interesting application
because
all of that simulation is occurring in
python in fact
the code that i kind of inherited from
my engineers
is this really huge thousand
of lines of python code that handles the
the simulations here
and what we struggled with uh before the
reticulate package
was how to make this code accessible to
others
you know no one on our team had the the
skill to build out
a full-fledged web application framework
in python
and so what we would end up doing is
taking requests from different
stakeholders
we would run these functions manually
and then we would
return the results and it was a really
time intensive and laborious process
so when the reticulate package came out
i was excited to be able to build
using the amazing tools available and
are around shiny
i was excited to build this type of
application
that would allow those stakeholders to
run experiments interactively themselves
and so i want to show you a little bit
of the code just so you get a feel for
what this looks like
inside of the application we're using
the reticulate package
to source this python file
and this python file has a whole bunch
of functions inside of it that do all
the heavy lifting
you can see one of them here is a sim
drive
and once you've sourced that file
all you have to do is call it call that
function as
if it were an r function you can see
that call here
and the reticulate package takes care of
all the the dirty work for you so
you don't have to worry about managing a
sub process yourself
you don't have to deal with type
conversions our data frames on the r
side are going to become those
dictionaries that the python function
needs
and then the python function is going to
return results that are nicely
handled back into a tidy data frame and
so
a lot of that heavy lifting is done for
you and it becomes really seamless
to get started calling that that python
code
from the r interface now when you're
doing that type of work
uh you know combining r and python
together it's not only
enough to be able to do that seamlessly
but you also typically don't want to
have to context switch
and so that leads to the second thing i
want to show you which is that inside of
our studio
again based on the open source work
that we've done with the reticulate
package you're able to
interact with python files directly and
so this is a pretty simple python file
and what i can do inside of our studio
is execute the code
kind of line by line in this case we're
using
numpy in matplotlib to create a
bivariate
distribution plot you can see the
matplotlib
image shows up in the plots panel our
python code is being executed line by
line in the console and we
even get some of the the really nice
ergonomics that you would expect from an
ide
such as autocomplete in the python
context
as well as help and this is really
exciting because
if you are you know inheriting those
python files
or gluing them together with our code it
can be really nice to be able to
interact with the python files in one
place
without having to switch context to a
totally different editor
or a different tool so rstudio you know
by no means
is going to be a full-fledged
id for python development at this time
but
in my experience as a data scientist
working with both of the languages
it meets my needs and has a lot of the
things i'm looking
for so that's how you might interact
with a python file directly
there's one other integration that we
built inside to make working with r and
python together pretty seamless
and that's through our markdown our
markdown if
you're not familiar with it and you're
coming from the python side of the world
it's very similar in its goal to a
jupiter notebook
it allows you uh to do what we call
literate programming
we're going to combine uh text and prose
alongside the output of code and all in
a single
scientific notebook or computational
document
so that's what our markdown allows you
to do but it's a little bit of a
misnomer
or a markdown because you can actually
use a whole bunch of different languages
inside of an arm markdown document of
course as you might guess we're talking
about python today
so i'm going to show you is how you can
use python and r
inside of this document we'll start by
inserting a python code chunk
and then let's load some data from the
seaborne
python library and specifically we're
going to
look at our favorite iris data set
you can see the ids autocomplete at work
helping me get these function calls
right and then we're going to use
some panda syntax to subset this
this data set that we've loaded and
specifically
we're going to look at one species of
iris
called the septosa and actually let's
not overload our variable names here
we'll call this setosa
and we can execute this right inside of
our studio
uh in the python context we can double
check that we got things right here
and so this does look like the iris data
set with the setosa
species so we're looking good so far
what i want to show you and where things
get kind of magical and really exciting
is that from our r code chunk we can now
access everything we were just doing in
the python
environment so specifically let's
load the ggplot2 library
and we're going to take a look
at this at plotting this data set
and the the way this works is there's a
special object in
our environment called pi that gives us
access to the python
environment and all the variables or
data that is in that environment
so here we have pi dollar sign setosa
is going to give us access to that
pandas data frame
and we can go ahead and plot it we don't
have to
from there we can do everything as if we
were in r
uh this will just make a simple plot
here
uh and what's really interesting about
this is it allows us to
use the languages for what they're
really good at so and as an example here
we're using pandas which is a pretty
powerful tool for data manipulation
and then ggplot2 which is really
excellent you know for visualization and
so we can run this
our code uh and of course
we get an error here uh let's maybe
see if we can figure out what's going on
with this error real quick
um one of the things that's really nice
is with that
python environment i can actually use
some of the ids features to explore
what's going on
so as an example i can view the data set
that's in python
using the view command and it looks like
this is the data set we saw
it's the iris filtered down to the
satoshi species
and actually i think i know what i did
wrong it looks like on the
python version this data set we have
underscores
i used periods so if we replace those
periods
with underscores there we go we get our
nice ggplot2 of the
relationship between length and width
so those are just a couple of ways that
a data scientist can combine or in
python inside of our studio
all of that is using the open source
tools that's going to be available
wherever you're running our studio at
the heart of it is that reticulate
package
the reticulate package uses the python
and rc plus plus apis so the data
conversions are pretty fast
it does use a little bit more memory
than if you were using a single language
but it allows you to take advantage of
tools
in each language so you can use r for
what it's really good at
in python for what it's really good at
and just to kind of recap what we saw
there
there is a combination of r and python
in our markdown so we just looked at
we also saw at the very beginning how
you can use python functions and execute
python code
in the context of our scripts or
functions
which is really useful if you want to
build like a shiny app that pulls in
python code and then you can also just
edit and play with python code directly
in our studio as the ide now that's
really useful
uh for for a data scientist to to glue
these two languages together
but what we see is that often it's not
just a data scientist who has to worry
about
r and python and the combination of the
two especially in organizations
there's another really important team
that gets involved with these two
languages
and that's the devops or i.t
administration group
that is responsible for creating that
environment
where data scientists can be productive
and have access to data
and collaborate with one another what
we tend to see you're working with a lot
of these organizations
as they're adopting are is that
it can be a challenge to create an
infrastructure
that meets the needs of all these
different languages
and what happens kind of in the worst
case scenario is that data scientists
will just
continue doing work on their own
desktops where they're most comfortable
and that becomes really hard to
troubleshoot um you know we've talked to
it admins who have
hundreds of tickets in their system
along the lines of
this version of a python package isn't
installing and so i can't share a
notebook with my colleague
and so what we're excited to show you is
rstudio's professional products
our studio server and rco connect which
together can make up our studio team
and these professional products allow
the devops and it group
to provide that single infrastructure
where
data science teams can use r and python
together and they can do it in their
favorite tools
whether that's our studio or jupiter
without you know resorting back to their
their desktop
that makes it easier for them to
collaborate and work together
but it also means that it only has to
configure
maintain you know scale a single
environment instead of dealing with
different tools for different languages
across different teams so i want to show
you what that looks like
actually going back to our studio and
one of the things that those of you with
uh
really astute eyes might have noticed is
that i'm actually using
our studio inside of a web browser which
might be a little bit different
especially if you're used to using our
studio as a desktop application
the reason that you see our studio
presented in a web browser
is because all the computation here is
happening on a server
and what that means is that lou myself
and the other data scientists at our
studio
are all working on a consistent platform
so it's easier for us to share work with
one another
it's easier for to get access to the
production data that we use at our
studio
and uh kind of one of my favorite parts
is that
i have a single entry point for all the
different types of projects that i work
on
and so this is the rstudio server home
page you can see the
shiny application that project we were
just in
is sitting idle now on the server i have
a job that i kicked off
a couple of hours ago that's kind of
running in the background i don't have
to worry about desktop updates
interfering with that job uh and the
kind of new thing that we wanted to
showcase is that
when you go to start a new session on
rstudio you now get to select what
editor you want
so of course you can choose the rstudio
ide
and our studio server will run that for
you but you can also pick between things
like jupiter lab
and the jupiter notebook it's also like
jupiter notebook
and we'll kick this off in a second but
before we do that
i also want to call out another choice
that's really powerful
which is where you want the computation
to actually run
so traditionally you would normally run
r and python
kind of on the same environment in the
same location where
our studio server was running but
in one of our goals to make the server
and this infrastructure more extensible
and easier for it
we've added the ability to offload some
of that computation to other locations
and so specifically what you're looking
at here
is the integration between our studio
server and a kubernetes cluster
our kubernetes cluster happens to be
running in aws
but you can run it be running kubernetes
on any of the cloud providers or even
on premise yourself and what this allows
me to do as a data scientist is without
learning any new tools or new
workbenches
right from within our studio server i
can pick
the profile of tasks that i'm going to
have so
what cpus i need the size of memory that
i want
and then my it group has put together
a couple of images docker images that
will control the environment
uh where where this jupiter notebook is
going to run
so this gives a lot of flexibility for
our team to specify exactly what we're
looking for
while still scaling elastically and
that's all inside of our studio we don't
have to
jump between different tools or
different environments
and so if i start this session you'll
see on the home page
the rstudio id as well as the jupyter
notebook
i can fire up this jupyter notebook and
it's going to give me
the same files the same access that i
had
from rstudio and so like many data
scientists
see i don't do a great job cleaning up
my workspace i have a whole bunch of
things going on here
but i can open up a specific set of
examples
that i created for today all these
examples
and code are going to be online and
we're happy to share them after the
webinar
but i just want to show you what it
looks like to run a jupiter notebook
here
and it actually might be a little bit of
a letdown
because what it looks like is a jupiter
notebook
you're able to execute the code chunks
inside of jupiter
you can see the results and we've tried
really hard at our studio to give you as
short a path as possible to the tool
that you're comfortable with
so we don't require a steep learning
curve around anything else
we just give you access to jupiter right
away
inside of this notebook though we are
still in that server-side environment
which is really nice because it means
that the python kernels that we have
are kind of shared and can be shared
amongst different data scientists
so if you're onboarding someone new to
python they're going to have access to
that shared environment that your it
group has set up
in this case that shared docker image so
that we're all kind of playing from the
same playbook
and while that's you know desirable a
lot of the time for
advanced python power users you still
have the ability to create your own
kernels
set up your own virtual or con
environments for specific projects
so all that same tooling is available to
you
the only difference between this jupyter
notebook launched through our studio
server and you know a jupyter notebook
you might run yourself
uh are two buttons that you'll see here
so one
is this r studio icon and you can tell
it really is a love story the two icons
are even sitting next to each other
and this just takes you back if you want
to your uh homepage
where you can see all the different
projects and contacts that you're
working on
inside the jupiter notebook if we go
back to that running notebook
the other icon that you'll notice is
this publish button
and we'll talk about that in just a
second so remember that icon
so to summarize for devops and it
one of the things that's really critical
when you have r and python users
is being able to provide them a
consistent entry point
that has their favorite tools without
introducing a whole bunch of headaches
and hurdles and our studio team is an
easy way to do that
and a single product only configured and
integrated once
you're able to give folks access uh to
the r studio id
on the r side which you know folks know
and love as well as their favorite tools
on the python side such as jupiter
notebooks
we'll be extending that suite of editors
as well
and that corresponds to an extension in
the number of backends too so i showed
you kubernetes
as one way to to run and execute these
content there's also
plugins if you want to run these
different editors
on more traditional hpc infrastructure
that you might have at your organization
so we've covered data scientists we've
covered it and ops
there's a third set of important folks
that lou mentioned at the beginning
who care about r and python and that's
the data science team leaders or data
science managers
and ultimately the business stakeholders
and we combine these together
on a single slide because we believe
their
concerns are largely you know two
sides of the same coin on the one hand
data science leaders
you know they're looking at how do i
onboard new users
into these different ecosystems where
they can collaborate with the team
without having to reinvent your wheels
or spend time doing translation
i was talking to one manager at
a pharmaceutical company they're trying
to get more than 500 sas
users into these open source tools so it
becomes really important
that as you do those trainings and
onboardings it's a seamless process
business stakeholders meanwhile if they
share some of the same goals of the data
science leader
they really want to see a return on
their investment in the data science
team
uh and ultimately what they care about
more so than whether
you use rn python is just getting
insights
from the team so they can make good
decisions and
not rely only on their intuition and
critical to doing that is their ability
to interact with the team
quickly we want to avoid slow iteration
times
and emails back and forth asking for
requests
between the different team members
and so the last thing i'll kind of show
you is how
our studio team in combination with r
and python
allows you to address some of these
challenges and specifically
we're going to look at what it means to
take some of those python and r data
products
and put them into production on a tool
that we call rstudio connect
and so i'm going to switch back here to
the shiny application
that we started the demo with
and this application as we mentioned at
the beginning
one of the things that's really nice
about a shiny application
is that it gives you the ability to
allow stakeholders
who may have specific domain expertise
to play around with your code and run
experiments
the challenge here is that right now
this application
is kind of trapped on my development
environment
it's not easy to share if i you know
close out of
our studio the application goes away
and so we need to do is move it into
production into a place
where others are going to be able to
interact with it and rely on it
and in our studio it's easy to do that
through that publish icon we were
talking about
so all i have to do to deploy this to my
production connect server
which is a server that's running on
premise i'm not
locked in to a platform as a service i'm
not sending my data
outside my firewall i'm just deploying
to another server
with a production intent is click
publish
and what's going to happen is that the r
and python environments are going to be
identified
all the different files and packages
that are in use
are going to be listed and then sent to
rstudio connect
where that environment is going to be
restored and the application is going to
be run
so i'll uh kind of like those old
cooking shows
this is the ingredients and i'm going to
jump to the end
uh pulling the final product out of the
oven but this is where
the application will live and what it'll
look like
after it's deployed to our studio
connect
and so the the application here will
load for us it's the
same application we've been playing with
the whole time but now it's in a
production context
and so what does that mean well very
critically it means that i have a stable
url
i can share with stakeholders and then
they can go and access this dashboard
and not even to need to know that it was
written in r or in python they don't
need to know the details
it just becomes a web application i also
have
a lot of those things that it is going
to care about so i can specify
specific users so that this environment
is secure and
locked down to specific users or groups
i can look at the logs
so i don't have to email someone in it
to
you know try to download a log file and
send it to me i can actually
look at those and kind of iterate and
debug in real time
then also very critically i can scale so
we've
used our studio connect to scale to more
than 10 000 users
at a single time so 10 000 concurrent
users
looking at a dashboard that involves
both r and python
so it's really good at managing all
those processes and connections for you
so that's an example of a shiny
application that is going to allow
you know business stakeholders to get
value really quickly and to be able to
iterate and run their own experiments
but dashboards and applications aren't
the only thing that data science teams
create
in fact one of the things that we were
talking about at the beginning
was those jupiter notebooks and so you
can publish jupiter notebooks
to rstudio connect and that becomes a
really powerful way
for teams to share their work you can
you have a notebook that documents your
experiment
your thinking and that'll be available
to everyone
and we have that support for jupiter
notebooks but also for our markdown so
it doesn't matter what language you're
using
your work can be shared in a single
place that becomes
a ground truth for the knowledge that
the data science team has
the other thing that you can do with
these notebooks that gets really
powerful
is once they're deployed to connect
connect can run them on a
schedule and so i actually want to show
you an example
of in our markdown document this
document is scheduled
to run twice a week we can look at the
historical
versions of this document that have been
published over time but one of the
things that's really
interesting about this our markdown
document is that it's designed to
communicate with stakeholders
so essentially what it's doing is every
twice a week on mondays and wednesdays
it checks inventory supplies
it runs a forecast and a burn down
analysis
and then if there's a discrepancy
between the inventory and the forecast
it actually uses code in our studio
connect scheduler
to send an email to stakeholders in this
case the supply team
and that email is fully customized
through the code
so you can include results you can
include plots
and those are going to show up in your
stakeholders inbox so they can look at
it right on their phone
and that's helpful in those cases where
people want to
get alerts or monitor something without
having to constantly refer back to a
dashboard that's available
for our markdown documents that are
again allowing you to combine
python and art together so it's a
powerful way to operationalize some of
that work
that the team is doing the one other
piece of content or pillar of content
that i will show you on connect
is how you might go about deploying a
model
so often data science teams are
responsible for creating models
and we've kind of seen how models could
be shared with people
in something like a dashboard or a
notebook
but often you also need to share those
models with other services
maybe it's a website maybe it's a
application
written in something like java but those
tools want to consume
the smart insights that you've created
and are in python
and the way that you can do that easily
is by hosting your model
as a restful api so i just want to give
you an example of what that looks like
on rcu connect
the code for this api so you can get a
sense for what it looks like to actually
write it
is something we'll share after the
webinar but in this case
our model is a sentiment predictor
so essentially the model takes as an
input a string
so maybe something like the word
debugging and we call this model
on connect uh using a restful request
it looks like this so this is something
a software engineer would be really
familiar with
and then the model returns the sentiment
0 being negative if the phrase was
not very happy or 1 being really
positive
in this case debugging is not very
positive
if we send the model something like
great beer
uh turns out that great beer is uh
quite a bit more positive and much
closer to one
and so this model is using our uh it's
also using python uh
a python library called spacey is
actually what's giving us the sentiment
scores
and just like we saw with the
application the shiny app
rca connect is handling the access
controls the logs
scaling the number of processes to
handle requests
so there's a lot of flexibility here as
you
operationalize these models
and so to kind of summarize you know
really what we're after
is making it easier for people to make
important decisions with data
and that's going to require teams to use
r and python together
and there are some considerations for
team leaders and stakeholders
when they set out to do that the big
ones are being able to access those
insights consistently and reliably which
is really what production means
and for teams it's being able to deliver
that content
regularly and seamlessly and so that's
what our studio team and specifically
our studio connect is designed to do
it's to help those decision makers
really rely on those data insights and
to ultimately get a return on the
investment
from the data scientists work in any
language
so with that i'm going to hand things
back over to lou
to kind of recap what we've talked about
and look ahead into the future a little
bit
thank you sean i appreciate that that
was a great
series of demos illustrating um the way
that we help
our customers tackle the major
challenges of bilingual teams
so just recapping what sean just showed
through our products we allow data
scientists to combine r and python in a
single project
using the reticulate package we make it
easy for these data scientists to launch
jupiter notebooks or jupiter lab from
the same infrastructure
where they launched the rstudio ide
from the devops and i.t perspective we
make it
possible to provide all this capability
in a single infrastructure for both r
and python and jupiter which means users
can continue to use their favorite tools
whether it's their studio ide
or whether it's a jupiter notebook
and you know very importantly from the
devops perspective they're making their
users happy
while making their own lives simpler and
less expensive by configuring and
integrating and scaling and securing a
development infrastructure just once
as opposed to multiple times from the
data science leaders point of view
we've shown how it's easy now to
collaborate across your team
sharing your r and python work between
those team members
maximizing their productivity and how to
really
repeatably reproducibly
deliver value to the business by
delivering regularly updated reports
custom results and self-serve
applications
through a single portal or directly in
your stakeholder's inbox via email
and from the business stakeholders point
of view it's possible for them to access
all these up-to-date
interactive analyses dashboards and
emails making sure that these results
are
current since they can be updated on a
scheduled basis
and so that they can get the answers the
insights they need
when they want them in order to make
better decisions
next slide please
all these capabilities around
integrating with jupiter notebooks
supporting jupiter environments
supporting these diverse bilingual teams
these are all available
in our commercial products our
commercial products are bundled together
in our studio team and made up of three
main components
our studio server pro which provides the
development infrastructure
for r and python rstudio connect which
is a platform that allows the data
scientists to publish their results
to business users and other
collaborators so they can use those
insights
and our studio package manager which
manages all the complexity
around our packages to surface and the
other two platforms
these three products together form our
studio
team and serve and serve the needs of
these different personas
next slide and
to date we've had up to we have had well
over a thousand large organizations
that use our commercial products to
solve their day-to-day data science
challenges and really scale up their
data science
usage into production so they can
leverage the value of their data science
team really maximize
the value of the investment and all the
different data science products they've
done whether it's r or python or spark
or kubernetes or
something else leverage all that value
to get better answers to make better
decisions and really really
maximize the impact of their data
science work
next slide please
as part and we've talked now a lot about
what's available in our products both
open source and commercial
in addition to that our studio for many
years has been
a major supporter of the art community
and now we're supporters of the python
community as well
the r studio community is a great portal
on our website for asking and answering
questions
around open source data science r and
python and our products
great place to get information every
year we sponsor our studio comp
which is the biggest gathering of open
source data science users in the world
we've got our next conference coming up
just in a couple of weeks
if any of you are going to be in the san
francisco area at that time where we
have a couple of slots
available left in that if not we're also
going to be live streaming the
presentations and we'll provide that
link
at the end of the presentation
the our studio education team is devoted
to
helping train the next million open
source data science users
we provide capabilities around not only
pointers to
other learning materials and our own
learning materials
but we also provide a train the trainer
certification
so that we can train um
people in the open source data science
community in uh
teaching on r and really encourage them
to scale out and provide training to
others because we feel like that's the
best way to really
get the capabilities for using our out
across the community
we're also a member of a number of cross
vendor groups
that help support the data science
community we were
one of the founders of the our
consortium which is focuses on
delivering valuable infrastructure and
supporting working groups
for the our community we're now major
sponsors of num focus as well
which is another cross fender group for
supporting investment
in open source data science they're the
umbrella organization that provides the
primary
funding for the jupiter project and
we're helping incubate ursa labs uh
providing operational support and
infrastructure for this industry-funded
development group
which specializes in developing open
source data science tools
that cross languages including most
recently the apache aero project
next slide
and so before we wrap up and head to
questions just a few links
on where you can find more information
to get an overview of what we talked
about today
and links to a lot more um
detailed information your your one stop
uh landing page is rstudio.com
python lots of information there you can
also contact us
to learn more that's a great way if you
want to get a detailed demo
if you want to get some questions
answered or just do a deeper dive
that's the best way to do it we will get
to as many questions as we can today
but there are a ton which is awesome we
appreciate the engagement
if we don't get to your question today
we will follow up
the link to the webinar recording as
well as the slides as well as
the scripts that sean used today all
that will be provided
to the attendees we've gotten several
questions on that
as i mentioned our conference is coming
up in two weeks you can
um click on this link we'll be able to
get more information about it
and uh when once the conference starts
you'll have access to the live stream
um where you'll be able to learn more
after the conference we
post those recordings on our website
those so those will all be available as
well
if you missed the live stream uh
in the first section of his demo sean
focused on using the reticulate package
to call python
from within r and so here's a couple of
links on
the website for the package examples and
a deeper dive webinar for using them
we also got a number of questions around
configuration and versioning and whatnot
and i'll hand a couple of those off to
sean in a minute
but for some of the deeper information
there again
our documentation is a great source for
that we can provide you information
and as always the rstudio community is a
great place
to ask and answers a whole bunch of
questions around
our products and using our python
so with that we'll dive into questions
as i said
if we will do our best to get to all
your questions if we don't we'll follow
up if you'd like to set up a
conversation
this is a great this link is also in the
slides but
you can click on this and it'll give us
a chance to directly set up
a follow-up conversation with you
so um diving into the questions i said
there's a ton i appreciate it
i also want to apologize to everyone who
suffered any audio problems so we had a
handful of people
uh with issues on that if you had any
audio problems
then this recording the full recording
will be sent out along with the slides
um so sean we've got a number of
questions here
one uh that comes up a few times is
you know can you clarify the difference
between what's available in our open
source
products and the work we provide there
and what's unique to our commercial
products around support for python and
jupiter
yeah absolutely so we're dedicated to
making
open source tools available for for data
scientists
and so everything that we were looking
at at the very beginning
is open source to the reticulate package
and that includes
everything that you saw inside of the
rcu ide
so the ability to switch back and forth
between languages inside of our markdown
the ability to run python scripts inside
of the id
as well as the reticulate packages
capabilities
for combining the r and python runtimes
for example the shiny application that
was calling
python functions that's all available in
the open source ecosystem
and you can get started today on your
desktop with the reticulate package
the commercial products are really
geared for those organizations
who are supporting teams working in both
languages
and so as we were talking about it as
well as the business stakeholders
we showed some examples of our studio's
professional team products
and that's specifically going to be when
you saw our studio server
working with kubernetes to run a jupyter
notebook that's
limited to the commercial products and
then rco connect which is that
platform for sharing production assets
whether they're applications or
notebooks or reports
that's a commercial product as well
excellent thank you sean
so i'm going to try and synthesize uh
several questions here
because they're they there are a couple
of big groups that they fall into
some of them fall into at least one is
there's a series of questions
that's along the lines of why should i
learn
python one question are asked does the
data scientist need to know all the
languages
another questioner asks what's better in
r another questionnaire asks
what's better in python and one
questionnaire suggests
that in our ggplot and shiny are
particular strengths
of r that python users might want to
leverage so any thoughts there
yeah those are great questions uh i
think
what we've really come to appreciate is
that
kind of pitting r and python against one
another
just isn't really practical for data
scientists and data science teams
at the end of the day people are coming
from different backgrounds
some have learned r some have learned
python some have learned both
and so really the the conversation to
have
is how do you use r and python together
you know
that kind of love story idea as opposed
to
which languages is best both are going
to be around for the long term
uh and it is really going to depend on
kind of your context
there's a lot of domain specific
packages in both languages
so if you're working in the insurance
industry versus in the finance industry
you might find yourself
using your different packages for
different needs um
so so i know that's a little bit of
dodging the question
the key thing i think is is to not get
hung up
on you know should i only learn r or
should i only learn python
really both languages are going to be
needed to succeed
excellent thank you there's another
series of questions that are all around
configuration and versioning there's one
set of questions
that asks well i don't see this option
what version of our studio products do i
need
there's another question that asks does
this support python two
or three or both and then third a more
general set of questions around how is
installation and configuration and
versioning
of python uh handled yeah those are
really great questions so let me quickly
go back to our studio id uh
rstudio 1.2 is going to be the version
that
has uh this built-in support uh
so that's what you should look for and
you can see your version of our studio
and just help
about our studio 1.2 is what what you're
going to look for there
you'll also want to install the
reticulate package that's going to
unlock a lot of this capability
and if you do try to use like an r
markdown document with r and python
the ide can guide you towards installing
that package as well
uh so that's kind of the the jumping off
point
there's two topics around configuration
so one is how do i handle configuration
if i'm working with others and we talked
a lot in the webinar about how it's
helpful
to be running our studio on a
server-side environment
where it can work with you to have a
consistent environment for the team
so that when you get started either in a
jupiter notebook or
inside of our studio you have a kind of
shared playbook
that's a baseline environment whether
that's r or python
or the sets of packages required by both
uh so that would be my recommendation
especially if you're working with others
specific to python management uh
inside of our studio for those of you
that are combining r and python together
the reticulate uh package has a whole
bunch of functions that specify
what python environment to use so if
you're familiar with like virtual
environments or conda
you can create those and then tell r to
use them
there's also functions for creating
those things
so if you're more of an r user but you
know you need to install some python
packages to get things to work
you can take a look at those create and
install
functions so there's a lot of
flexibility there
there's a reticulate cheat sheet
available online that's going to walk
through
a lot of that stuff and then the one tip
i would give folks
is that the pi uh config
pi discover config so this function here
uh is really helpful in that it tells
you kind of
what a version of python has been
identified
is in it and is in use by the r session
uh kind of looking ahead one of the
things we're really excited about
working on this year
is extending the support for reticulate
so that you're able to do a bit more of
that environment management
uh from the rcu ide with a little bit of
help
you know interactively through the ui
so hopefully that answers some of the
questions there lou there's
a question on um
will this functionality be available in
our studio cloud
yeah excellent question so our studio
cloud
today does not have the the python
environments installed
um but if that's something that's
interesting to you we'd love to to chat
about
you know what types of projects you're
hoping to work on
for those that are completely unfamiliar
our studio cloud
is an environment for
kind of right now specifically geared at
teaching though it also can be useful
for for individual projects as well
uh what it essentially is is a version
of our studio
that we run so everything we were
talking about today
in the webinar was for teams that are
maintaining
their own infrastructure or running our
studio just locally on your desktop
but if you're an educator and you want
to teach students about
r and python it can be really annoying
to
have to spend the whole you know first
week of class just trying to get r and r
studio
and python and jupiter all installed and
so rstudio
cloud solves that problem for you that's
support for
uh what we call different workspaces so
you can set up a class
invite students to that class and then
they have an r studio environment
that's configured and ready to go and so
if you're interested in using python in
your courses
alongside of r and we'd love to hear
from you so that we can understand
what your requirements are on python
might be someone in the question box had
called us out for having python 2.7
in our environment and you're absolutely
right
python 2 isn't supported anymore but
practically it's still all around
we'd love to get your feedback
especially from educators
on what you're hoping to teach and what
that right environment might look like
for you
we got from one of the listeners who
like to know where they can find more
resources regarding use cases for data
scientists or devops and it admins
um perhaps you want to show
solutions.rtstudio.com real quick unless
you've got another suggestion on that
yeah absolutely so lou had mentioned
there's a lot of great resources
as part of this webinar that we'll be
sharing afterwards
um one of the the things i'll point you
to
is this site called rstudio solutions
it's available just at
solutions.rcu.com this is going to have
a bunch of those examples for what
workflows look like
for data science teams and this is based
on our interactions with more than a
thousand
commercial entities that are doing work
you know running both of these languages
in production
and it's also going to give some
pointers for the i.t or devops
side of the house who are trying to
answer questions like what should our
architecture look like
you know should we be doing things in
kubernetes should we do
doing things in the cloud should be
running things locally
so so all those questions are answered
here then of course we're happy to talk
with you as well
on the slides include that link
to set up a meeting if you want to
bounce ideas off of anyone on our team
so we have a few applica a few questions
around
deploying shiny apps onto connect and
how does that
how that works one asks whether or not
it's able to utilize a cluster behind
the scenes
another asks once it's published on
connect
who is going to continue management how
does it scale up
for more users to access and another one
asks whether it's possible to make that
available outside of firewall
yeah awesome questions really exciting
to hear about
you know people delivering those
applications into production that's
certainly
probably the top thing that our
customers are working on
is how to get shiny applications you
know off of your laptop or your
development environment
into somewhere that's more stable we can
answer those
questions specifically if folks have
them
um what i'll show you here connect is
basically a product that runs on a
server
it scales horizontally so if you you
are concerned about having more people
visiting your application
than a single server can handle you can
add multiple servers just like you would
with any other web application
and place them behind a load balancer
the deployment
happens in a variety of ways i showed
you push button publishing
rco connect also knows how to integrate
with git
so if you want to have a more get
centric workflow you can do that
once the content is deployed there's a
lot that happens
to help you manage kind of the ongoing
life cycle of that content
so we mentioned that you can look at the
logs uh we talked about
some of those scaling settings that'll
you know help
as you go to do that type of horizontal
scaling
and then there's also things like
default source versions
the ability to roll back and forwards in
time so there's just a lot
of options there at the end of the day
our goal what we're trying to do is help
bridge that gap that often exists
between data scientists who are creating
these amazing applications and then i t
operations
who know a ton about servers and about
best practices around things like
infrastructure as code but might be less
familiar
with r and python and so rco connect
acts as that bridge uh to serve a really
nice balance where data scientists don't
have to
you know learn the gory details of
server management
and itops doesn't have to learn the gory
details of things like our packages
the two can kind of meet and still have
that robust and reliable production
ready
service well on that note
we are just about out of time uh sean
and i and the rest of folks at our
studio would like to thank you again for
attending this webinar
we're very excited to share all the work
we've been doing around r and python and
how we help support bilingual data
science teams
in scaling out their data science across
their organization